hey !
comment allez vous ?
bienvenue dans mon salon de tatouages !
Comme vous le savez je dessine extraordinairement bien !
Donc j'ai décidé de dessiner sur la peau des gens !
Pour bien n**** le restant de leur vie !
aujourd'hui on est sur TEN SECOND TATOO
Et vous savez en 2016 les gens sont extrêmement pressés
Faut que tout aille vite et soit immédiat
et du coup même les tatouages
je voudrais me faire tatouer en 10 secondes bordel
c'est parti, premier client
je veux un robot patriote
ok c'est parti
euh un robot, ça c'est un robot
c'est bender de futurama
ok et là on va marquer
vive
la
fran..
OOOOOOOOOOOO
attend tend tend... je suis d'accord on est pas dans le thème
mais ont ta quand même fait p'tit biscuit de Shrek
Si tu veux le côté patriote , reviens demain  , je rajouterai un drapeau de la France et ça fera 200 balles
Ok Suivant !
Un loup démoniaque ! Alors euuh
En fait c'est une main qui fait l'ombre du loup
ça c'est la lumière et du coup l'ombre ça fait un loup ici regarde ! Hop voilà !
Tu es train d'essayer de ruiner ma vie ?
Alors le pénis de profil c'était pas voulu si je puis me permettre !
je ne sais pas pourquoi , mon imagination ne me permet pas de faire des... des bons dessins  !
Par contre des bons tatouages , ça ça va !
Suivant !
Dessine moi une glace personnalisé !
Une glace ? Alors c'est hyper simple , regarde !
ça c'est le bâtonner , ça c'est la glace ok
Et au dessus , on va faire la mer , c'est la mer  , attends la mer en bleu ! Voilà
Et la glace , on l'appelle la Iceberg !
Comme ça avec la mer ça fait un jeu de mot !
J'arrive pas à m'imaginer comment ça aurait pu être pire !
C'est comme ça , alors toi tu va te calmer sinon la prochaine fois , je vais te tatouer la pupille mon pote !
Tu la verra tous les jours ta glace ! Ok Suivant !
I need , tu need quoi t'es sur de pas bien préciser ce que tu veux ?
Ok mon pote ! On va te dessiner des piercings , un anneau au pif
Ah déjà un peu de barbe aussi parce que la t'es totalement en manque de barbe !
Oh nan ça fait 10 secondes , et hop un trait ! Put** mer**
On a déconné la , il faut jamais blaguer dans un salon de coiffure !
Dessine moi un Dauphin meurtrier !  What ?
Euh donc ça c'est le Dauphin ok
ça c'est l'aileron du Dauphin !
Et finalement c'est un oeuf au plat dans une toile qui est en train de cuire !
Voilà ce qu'on a fait !
Oh ouais , il est cool !
Bas ouai, faut me faire confiance mon gars. Suivant!
Put** on a oublié de respecté les règle d'hygiène
Aller on met les p'tit gants en latex que les infirmières on pour pas infecter la plaie
Hop, on est parti, ouai j'avais plus de gants,
en latex mais c'est pareil, y'a juste un max de dépots de fumée déchappement.
Mais c'est pas toxique. Alors la tatoué avec des gants mon pote *rire*
C'est dur. Un alien spirituel
Un esprit étranger, j'ai mal traduit. Euuuuuh
Je vais te faire un esprit étranger mon pote. Alors un esprit étranger
On va faire l'esprit de... Qui est étranger?
Ok, j'ai une idée mon gars. OK en noir. Clac
Clac
Voila, sa c'est l'aura euuh.. Sprituel euh. De l'esprit
De l'œuf de tout à l'heure. Travail incroyable
Puti**, vous adoré les œufs Attend je suis en train de lancer une mode
sur Paris là. Ca peut être bizarre , tu devrais faire uunnnn...
Et il a rien dit , *clap* on va bien s'occuper de ton cas mon pote!
Hop, hop
Hop, 100 kilos
Voooiiiila, on t'a fait un bel alter mon pote. I'm hideous!
Je veux pas savoir ce que sa veux dire.
Dessine moi  authentique carte. Ok... Attend
le tatouage il va te couté un bras mon pote hein, ok c'est parti.
Hop, hop, hop, hop. 2
2, 2, 2. Voooiilaa
j'tai fait une carte HearthStone, j'tai fait le
lanceur de couteaux, il coûte 2 y'a 2 2 *clap*
Sois pressé la prochaine fois, parce que oui la règle d'or
dans mon merveilleux salon de tatouages, c'est le respect envers
le client, le respect. Alors toi qu'est-ce qu'on va te faire? Oh des
ch'veux, voila ce qu'on va te faire put** , quel bonne idée.
Mon pote, pourquoi t'y a pas pensé avant? *rire*
Voooiiiilaa. Et même, et même un double sourcil
Voooiiilla, incroyable travail
On est stylistes à mis temps, on va pas se mentir, je veux
un papillon tribal, ah oui ok.
Ok, je vois le délire, alors c'est genre clac.
Clac, clac avec du noir, et la
tête et y'a pas de noir, là y'a du noir.
Là y'a un truc comme sa, un truc comme sa, voila c'est un peu
tribal. Hop, voila, tribal
*silence*
Attend, si sur Google on tape tribal butterfly.
Je suis sûr  sa ressemble comme 2 gouttes d'eau, regardez! Attend mec
C'est pas une pâle copie de ce qu'on viens de faire?
C'est pas un pur plagiat? Mec t'a pas honte de copier
les œuvres d'arts qui sortent de mon salon de tatouages, *musique calme* en plus y'a un double
sens à travers cette œuvre d'art, on peut aussi y voir
un visage. Et sa c'est, sa montre queee...
En dessinant le tatoueur a raconté une histoire,
voyez qu'il a créé un univers autours de son
œuvre. Bon ok je te rembourse , j'ai attendu sa toute ma vie.
Un poil, voila t'a vraiment 0
poils sur ton corps il fallait bien que tu en ait au moin un, j'aimerais avoir
une feuille de canabis spirituel, bas bien sûûûrrrre.
La voila t'a feuille de canabis, fumé tue
parce que c'est sa un salon de tatouages, c'est aussi des bons conseils,
pour aider le clients. I want a cursed mom!
Une sacré maman, sa c'est sa tête.
Ok, et là et bas là c'est une sacré maman
là, là on a un beau morceau hein, on va pas
se mythonné longtemps, avec le p'tit nombrils *clap* .
Je vais aller vivre seul dans les bois, c'est une bonne idée ouai.
Mais si je puis me permettre tu sera pas seul hein, tu sera avec t'a sacré maman.
J'ai voulu sa toute ma vie, une...
Moustache d'Hitler *clap* horrible.
Tu dois être nouveau dans ce métier. Comment dire
*rire* Je veux un arc-en-ciel macho, bas y'a pas de
soucis, hoop, hoop
Mei là, une petite moustache.
Oh non mais la c'est pas possible mec *rire*
Nan mais là faut que je change de métier j'arrive pas
avec la souris mec c'est impossible, ah j'avais plus mes gants c'est pour
sa, j'ai plus mes gants. Hop! *bruit de frappe*
Là on est bon, fait moi une machine à écrire alors sa
c'est ma spécialité, sa si je puis me permettre, oh
la, la, là y'a tout. Là y'a tout.
Y'a les touches du claviers, la feuille A4 prête à recevoir
des coups euuh.. Qui imprime les lettres
dessus, celui la on va le mettre dans le, le livre de déco
du salon. Hey! J'aimerais avoir un joli drapeau.
Ouuii, et voila je fini avant le temps en plus hein.
J'ai fais le drapeau de l'île des poneys avec des p'tites couleur qui
vont dans le rose, dans le fluo, dans leee...
Toi tu kiff pas? J'aimerais un
squelette de bateau. Ok mon pote *expiration*
Un max d'hygiène *crache*
Encore plus d'hygiène *rire* On assure la
sécurité du salon, c'est parti!
*musique épique*
Ouai, bon là on dirait carrément une baguette
de pain. *musique épique*
*musique épique*
Ah *salue la foule* * crie de foule*
Alors là mon gars tatouage de l'année.
Putin, les faux raccords sur les gants *clap clap* c'est bon
vous avez rien vue
Oui bon voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur 10 seconde pour faire un tatouage
N'hésitez pas à aimer si ça vous a plu
Et n'hésitez pas à me contacter j'aurais mis mes coordonnées dans la description
Si vous voulez un tatouage voilà tout ce qui est baguette de pain
squelette de bateau j... je m'y connais.
Allez à très bientôt dans prochaine vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé !
Tchaooo tout le monde portez-vous bien PEACE !
*musique*